welcome back it's a great pleasure to
introduce you to this panel where they
have given us the very very easy topic
of figuring out the future development
of artificial intelligence I'm very
honored to have a great set of panelists
help us figure this out Michael Levitt
Barbara gross to add Russell and Harry
Shum and it's great to have this
diversity also where we have both them
ten years on the academic side of
artificial intelligence Mike Stewart
Russell and Barbara gross who are both
doing artificial intelligence research
basically just after I got out of
diapers or actually but when I was six
and eight years old and at the same time
having this wonderful industry
perspective from from Harry Shum who
leads up Microsoft's technology
development and also from the
perspective of using computer technology
to do wonderful science like Michael
Levitt is dabbled a little bit in
chemistry picked up the Nobel Prize for
you know for fantastic use of computers
that understand nature better so as we
take on this very large question of the
future of the field of AI let's try to
structure it a little bit by starting
with a near-term future and then towards
the end go farther afield and think
about more long-term questions the
beginning at the near term we all know
that on one hand reycarts while gave us
this very optimistic picture this
morning where you you have this curve
steady progress just going to keep
getting better and at the same time a
lot of people talk about the sociology
of the field having gone through maybe
three cycles of huge hype and then a lot
of disappointment so my first question
is if each of you if you could just
briefly comment five ten years from now
do you think you will then be
celebrating the continued awesome
progress of AI or that you'll be
complaining they were stuck in another
AI winter do you want to so i can start
maybe i continue what i mentioned you
morning I would say you look at a I look
at the various subjects of a eyes I was
saying five to ten years for sure enough
speech recognition we see the computer
recognition lovely in a speech will be
just as good as what we can perceive as
human out in 10 years maybe I'll still a
little bit of stretch if we think about
in the computer vision in a visual
recognition of objects and different
kind of categories but we'll probably
getting pretty close Jane or AI i think
is still a long way to go let's do it so
i like to think that we will finally see
some real progress in robotics and
stomachs and has been a chicken-and-egg
that there's been a very difficult
mechanical physical problem of building
robots that have you know lightweight
rapid flexible motion that have
sensitive skin that have all kinds of
sensors that enable them to be very
dexterous so there's been this sort of
very slow improvement on the physical
side and it's hard to invest on the
physical side when the the robot
algorithms are not there to use it so if
you've seen the recent DARPA challenge
for humanoid robots you know a mighty
robot that a faceplant don't mind I mean
they spend most of their time trying to
get up after they've fallen over so I
think we should actually go to four
legged robots rather than two legged but
with the progress in computer vision I
think that it starts to become practical
to put robots into unstructured
environments which could be agriculture
which could be into the domestic
environment we're on the you know
current robots are extremely efficient
in manufacturing and other situations
where you can design the environment
around the robot so the robot doesn't
have to be intelligent to do its
function so that's one big set of
problems that I think will really see
progress on and the other I hope is
going to be the real understanding of
language so speech is is a wonderful
thing to be able to
to turn into text but if you don't
understand the text then the world's
best speech recognition system is
completely useless so the real
understanding of language means means
not that you can process you know 100
billion pages and you know and count how
many times the word Shakespeare appeal
or something like that it's it's that
you actually you know even if it's just
a page that you can really extract the
meaning and answer detail questions
about what was said why was it said how
does it relate to information or taken
from another document if that takes
place on you know with one page then
very quickly you'll see that scale up to
100 billion pages and then you've got
machines that are read and understood to
some degree everything the human race
has ever written and that will be a
capability that we can only begin to
guess how important that would be you
know it would put search engines Google
and so on into the shade as a technical
advance so we've heard lots of optimism
here both from Harry and from Stuart so
Barbara are you gonna pour cold water on
them and warn of an AI winter oh you're
gonna share the optimism so I want to
thank you max because I brought this
crystal ball here hey somebody asked me
to predict this and and it's not telling
me anything since since I but thank you
for making it worthwhile to have direct
it um since in in 1975 I predicted that
by 1980 we would have solved the dialog
problem I've given up this is a
tradition I didn't I actually had a full
plan for it you know I did means in
reasoning well we needed in 1980 so we
must have this by 76 77 said me get
there so um I think so first of all I
agree with what what in some sense both
Harry and Stuart said but i would i
would add one thing to it which is if we
take seriously what we talked about in
the previous panel with human computer
interaction and also take seriously that
we're not trying to replicate humans but
instead to augment them i think we can
take many of the partial solution
that Harry talked about and combine them
with with well-designed interfaces to
really increase what people are able to
do and here I mean both what people in
their everyday lives can be doing
because the machines are enhancing them
but also what scientists can do in their
own work which I think actually it is a
good segue over to Michael yeah thank
you your perspective back to the
original question about the ups and
downs of artificial intelligence and I
think you're getting up and down when
achievements don't match the
expectations and i would say instead of
blaming the achievements blame the
expectations for some reason the word
artificial intelligence leads the hyper
and this hype is not always achieved
very often also things are achieved that
weren't explains it I find it quite
difficult to distinguish between
computing artificial intelligence you
know big data it's all just using
computers to do things so for example
there are computers could multiply
phosphoryl i could probably in 1935 like
what's around then but I didn't see I
mean no one feels bad that computers of
better words multiplying and you know
playing chess 10 years ago computers
were the World Chess Champion chess is
still a very popular game now obviously
if you had a cheating computer in your
pocket a new plate just by cheating
there would be no different from taking
drugs when you in the Tour de France or
something like that it wouldn't be a lot
so I think this this whole issue about
computers sort of suddenly getting up
and putting us down it'll happen if we
want it but we don't have to have it
happen so I think that you know I
believe that there's going to be a rapid
advance in computing I'm not sure
exactly I think Roberts are going to be
terrific what I would love to see na in
the area of robots is a thousand-dollar
robots that can make an omelet on my
kitchen counter yeah it shouldn't be
that hard it's the sort of thing a
Kickstarter could maybe do but in other
words get robots the way that personal
computers are out there get out personal
Roberts that go beyond the lego
mindstorm and actually can do something
useful it should be possible that would
immediately change the whole area things
like that anyway I
I want to just address you know
something Michael said I think it is a
spot on you no no no the challenges we
have seen AI the what's really happening
right now what's really progressing the
fields the reason the years is really
because you know three things you know
one is computing is getting incredibly
fast amici choose with this is very very
important is actually have more and more
data that we can learn like speech like
fishing that we can learn of course we
also got very lucky that we have some
breakthrough in some latest algorithms
like a keep learning and other things
those specific things I made a lot of
this kind of progress today in a
becoming Alps reality as you talk about
this kind of 1000 that solid robot can
do some general things that they
probably will come I don't know how many
years we probably can tell us exactly
which year but we probably are not not
that sure ah so the the way you think
about this is where we actually still
face a tremendous challenge is actually
our inability to model uncertainty
things we actually don't really know in
a lot of this kind of big data machine
learning things actually trying to look
for something coming among the data but
what we really don't know let's just say
no which robot is more difficulty design
it's a flying drone no landing or
aircraft carrier or actually a little
robot moving your house I would argue is
the letter the reason for that is when
you don't really know how to model this
kind of uncertainty in different kind of
houses now from Sweden to us to China so
those things that we just don't really
know so those those are the most
difficult of problems I think as I think
about next 10 20 years of research so I
also want to pick up on the managing
expectations because I think that that's
a very important thing to do that and
what Harry said about the big data and
the faster computers is absolutely true
but of course the results are only as
good as the data that they have and
there are some problems for which either
large amounts of data are not available
or for which that's not going to be
sufficient but there are already I just
was reminded by
people were saying milind tombe has this
very nice work that we wouldn't so you
asked to predict in 2007 never no one I
think would have predicted that
Stackelberg games from economic theory
would make a difference in security and
yet in malaysia now those stack over
games are being used to protect wildlife
in the forests by doing something which
people are not good at which is
understanding uncertainty and randomness
and predicting where the poachers are
going to be so that's an example of
something that's here now that wouldn't
have predicted okay that's eight years
ago I think it's very very hard to
predict if you're if you're not trying
to create the AVA of ex machina which
I'm not sure we want or need but instead
trying to take the ideas that we have
and show where they can make a
difference in the world yeah those are
really interesting points you're making
it and Michael you I think you said it
very well there were you said that we
should really blame for the these
disappointments in the past is not the
progress which has actually been quite
impressive along but rather our
expectations that we let get completely
out of sync as the moderator I feel it's
my job to be the devil's advocate so
with all this optimism here about how
fast the technological progress I have
to ask nonetheless how can we be so sure
that this time is different that this
time all the optimism and the
expectations of how great things are
going to be in the next 5-10 years are
actually realistic and not again wishful
thinking brought on by good swedish food
and and so on so i would draw a
different curve which is that the
progress has been like this and that
there are breakthroughs and what we
understand algorithmically their
breakthroughs in material science the
breakthroughs in many things and I think
that a big difference now from the 1980s
when I first saw these great well I will
leave at the 1960s the 1980s is that
there are AI systems out in the world
now making a major difference in
people's lives there are recommendation
systems there are search engines so
it's there so now there's a sense in
which we can just do more as opposed to
we have having to do something yeah i
think if if progress gets to the point
where for example in speech recognition
where it becomes more valuable to a
person to to have a speech recognition
system even if it's not perfect then
it's just painful used to be just
painful to use a dictation system
because they would make more mistakes
and let it would take you twice as long
to fix so once it crosses that threshold
where it has real economic value then
then every extra one percent in terms of
performance is worth you know billions
of dollars and so there's this virtuous
cycle takes hold very quickly in terms
of investment from industry and i would
say in the last five years the
investment from industry has dwarfed
what government has put into AI in the
previous 50 years and that really makes
a difference the second big difference
is that you know in the previous cycles
of hype a lot of the claims were based
on so we say flimsy technological
grounds there was there was a very very
thin and almost non-existent theoretical
basis for a lot of the systems that were
being built and now the nature of the
field has changed completely so i'm
sorry to say for those of you who think
you you might enjoy going to an AI
conference that that is essentially a
hard to distinguish from a mathematics
conference it just slides as wise as
light full of equations and proofs and
results and complexity and all this sort
of stuff so the field has become very
rigorous very solid and and that has
resulted in this type of progress that
you see in physics and chemistry where
you're building on decades of really
solid mathematical modeling and theory
so we're here i actually agree you know
is the stu asset but that's a
practitioner myself in i walking
industry if you work on the products you
actually are forced are required to make
progress you know add some predictable
rate i have been listening to a lot of
thought leaders today talking about them
of predicting the future this is how i
think about i think
the progress of AI will neither be
linear not exponential I think it's
probably going to be more like a spiral
I think a linear is too boring
exponential too optimistic as in reality
is probably is more like a spiral just
going into multi-dimensional it's a
mathematical is it suck your thumb it's
all mathematical you know those curves
are 2 DT is only two dimensional not
happening sweetie I don't think actually
the multi-dimensional is exactly the
right point that there is no machine IQ
right and there's no so there's no way
of measuring progress that AI in a
single number humans to a rough
approximation have an IQ which means
that you know if someone is good at for
example translating between multiple
languages they're probably also good at
writing and they're probably also good
at reading and answering questions none
of those things are true of machines so
you know the world's best chess playing
program can't play any other game at all
even at the level of our one-year-old
there are systems that can translate
among 200 different languages as well as
any human being can't read a book to
save I lies they can't answer a single
question so they're totally unlike human
intelligence and they progress along
many of these dimensions hundreds of
dimensions of progress where they could
go along so long corridors of advancing
in these very narrow directions that
make systems that don't look anything
like a human being but a super
intelligent in a very restricted sense
so they might know more than in a useful
sense they might know more than any
human being has ever known or will ever
know but they still couldn't plan their
way out of a paper bag or still can't
make a nice omelet for Michael yeah yeah
so now that you've been all very
cautious and he did he did the barbers
advice that her crystal ball doesn't
really work and made this garden the
optimistic statements about the future
let's not throw all caution to do in
here because now I want to ask you
suppose we can we actually give
ourselves license to engage in some
wishful thinking I'm very curious for
each one of you to hear what is
your favorite AI based technology or
application that you would really love
to see come to fruition say and then
over the next decade and how would that
how would how would you like that to
impact your life and society let me
start and what I would love to have is
that use of an expert system like Watson
would be compulsory for all politicians
before the making decisions you can that
that this way we recorded like a police
camera ie you know George Bush Burgos
the machines say invade Iraq and if
cotton didn't say yes yes yes yes yes
then you have to say why he did this
against Watson decision and the good
thing is is that you know when you're
kind of powerful all your advisors just
tell you what you want to hear
presumably artificial intelligence would
be smart enough not to do that so I
really think this is something I somehow
feel that the simulation I mean so
government things are much harder than
the problems we have in biology or
chemistry by any any level and they need
to be tackled by similar methods and
assimilate what's going to happen
simulates we you know let Syrian
refugees into your we don't necessary
what is gonna be the outcome and follow
it through not one half a move ahead but
ten moves ahead like chess and actually
look it up look at the implications
people don't ever do this and this just
seems to me to be that they're basically
playing with our future and I think this
is something which one hopes would catch
on that then in some ways even just
applying stuff which is free prosaic and
you know one thing I was just thinking
about is so there's a lots of different
computer programs for guiding you in
your car there is a great one called
ways and if you don't know about it you
should know about it so but so basically
it it basically breaks all privacy
anyone using Waze is actually sending to
the server where he is and what speed is
going and therefore ways can tell you
exactly what you're doing because the
car in front of you is going to do
something different or similar but
what's really interesting about ways is
how it's a wonderful avoider of family
arguments I used to get into the car my
wife would say you go to the show away
I'd say no no I want to go
new way now if you go a new way and
you're delayed it's your fault if you
got the show when you delayed it's all
okay so this is a basic but you simply
say will do what way says and I keep
them thinking there needs to be a hot
efficient intelligence like that so for
example you know some question at home I
don't know change the curtains or
something like that have something that
we just tell you change them and after
one you get used to them and people
would be much happier living together I
worry so so in our panel just an hour
ago we talked a lot about machines that
need to use social and emotional
intelligence to make people happy so we
may find that AI is just telling you
what you want to hear anyway yeah so
your curtains are wonderful loving
happen but they all the credit yes to me
I think the most exciting thing that
look into the future really thinking
about AI is really this all-knowing
agent know for you and I think this is
Greek term called alter ego ah it's
really it's really about their second
self it's about yourself but I think it
does require the users to be willing to
cooperate to to our corporate with the
AI system such that we actually have a
chance to build a the AI it's very
important just to just take that the
micros example say no what kind of
advice is do you really want to gather
from your alter ego your from your a is
not an assistant you really want that to
be very personal but you can only build
that if you are willing to share with
your AI system what you like only
Michael knows how he actually everyday
interacts with his wife you know we're
probably doing very different i program
my program to myself a long time ago
whatever my wife says is correct that's
important that's harmony for the family
so that's so that's that's the principle
so that but everyone is different so you
have to program yourself such that you
actually have this then you get the real
really the right advice and other things
again I'm a big
liver in having the data and having the
computing to actually help you to get as
a I write to me I think this alter ego
thing is that is the most important more
pimples important and exciting AI system
in the future very interesting so what
is your wish so so now that we have
these dreams of solving all of
international politics and domestic
discord is very hard to think of
anything anything will sound long term
so um so I'm feeling like my my my
fantasies are rather mundane but um but
I really do hope to see them realized
and and I'll one of them is actually
related to what Michael said which is to
provide advice and and expertise to not
just to governments and people govern
but to enhance people's ability to
participate in government and to bring
what people at large have to have care
about to the people who are governing so
to make that kind of change and then
related to some of the health care that
I talked about before I would like to
see an intelligent system that really
helps a team of doctors become a team
and that raises a number of enormous
issues one of which I talked about
earlier which is what information to
share with whom when but it also the
both of these actually bring up an issue
which we may want to talk about more
which is the issue of when you shift
from a computer talking about taking
charge or something to a person taking
charge of something how that handoff
should happen and win and what
information should get conveyed they're
so great and Stewart so now that you
have not the crystal ball but the genie
in the bottle is you can make wishes i
know you've warned us about genies this
morning but if she if we get one wish
anyway for some great day i am naval
technology so i think
one of the things that machines can
really do for us in the relatively near
future is to collect and synthesize much
larger amounts of information than we
can handle and I can think of two
examples one which is quite close to
Michael's interest which would be the
massive amount of information we have in
molecular biology about the functioning
of cells and organs which is far too
much for any individual person to
understand there are about a million
papers published every year on these
topics then if you read any one of them
right there they named 500 molecules in
the first pages and so I think this is
regular just a cognitive capacity to
handle this is a real bottleneck so if
we could use that information and use it
to build a consistent picture which
wouldn't be a definitive picture because
we don't have definitive answers but it
would represent the uncertainty that we
have about information because one of
the biggest problems that's happening in
the life sciences and Social Sciences as
well is is that because of the
publication process and selection bias
for papers it turns out that many many
many major results on which people rely
turn out not to be reproduced all in
other word our way of saying it is
they're wrong right there are false
claims because you know you you look for
ninety five percent confidence in your
sista chol results from your data but if
you submit a hundred papers and only the
ones where the biggest results get
accepted then probably most of those are
going to be wrong it's just a fact about
statistics and so that's one what's one
area that we could build a consistent
consensus picture of what's solidly
known what's partially known what's
uncertain about the functioning of life
and obviously with applications for
medicine I'd like to do something
similar which is perhaps a little bit
more often left field and I can't see
that there's going to be a huge amount
of government investment in this but
actually to do the same thing with
history that you know you can find
journals where people spend their whole
lives looking at you know 12 clay
tablets with
salma Syrian something or others written
on them and then you know there's
another journal aware some other
specialists ancient language works and
there are many many of these silos where
there's incredible expertise but there's
no cross fertilization there isn't the
ability to put together this information
and actually understand what happened in
our history so this includes for example
the evolution of language the movement
of people's from genetic information
from from artifacts from texts from all
kinds of sources which could be a
wonderful way of learning about
ourselves our own histories and how
we've all evolved over time and our
culture's have grown and interweaved
over time so I think that would be a
really fun thing to spend one's life on
thank you for all these exciting ideas I
hope they all come true and helped genie
grants them and they go well during the
remaining of 10 15 minutes we have here
let's come back to this very broad
charge that we were given by the
organizers here to talk about the whole
future artificial intelligence and and
look farther afield here this is of
course we're where we have even less
knowledge becomes this is more a matter
of speculation before we get into any
details and hopefully interesting
disagreements we ask you're just a very
very simple question which you're only
allowed to answer with one word which
has to be a number okay so the question
is how many years from now will human
will will machines be able to actually
match human ability on all cognitive
tasks you can say infinity if you think
it's never gonna happen by all cognitive
tasks I mean not only playing chess and
translating French into Mandarin but I
also mean making a really good omelet
Alma let that you approve of if you plug
the machine into a sufficiently good
mechanical system so you can say a
number between zero and infinity when
you think there's at least fifty percent
chance that we'll have across-the-board
human level AI you want to go first let
me have a chance to qualify it
afterwards I have a request
yeah you won't be too surprised by this
question but everything you mentioned
was the kind of subject matter issue are
you also asking about machines that are
going to be good psychotherapist and
friends are we leaving that human k % of
human capabilities as I hope out of the
equation I would leave it up to you to
make your own definitions but I would be
very broad and say that's absolutely a
cognitive task because we do it with our
brains when we're psychologists so if
you think machines are you we're your
including the hypothalamus yeah
everything works so just say one number
really quickly and then it'll be very
interesting to see if there's a big
spread 300 years 300 years what about
you infinity cuz I wouldn't include the
hypothalamus okay and what about you I'm
not gonna give a number till the last
time I was asked to give a number was in
an officially off the record session
where journalists were not allowed to
take notes let alone report anything and
so I said off the record possibly within
a lifetime of my children one of whom
sitting in the front row there and
within 20 minutes the daily telegraph
reported you know scientist predicts
robots will overrun the world within a
generation I kid you not and this is the
literal truth so I'm very where are you
giving a number but even though you heed
diplomatically anything he did
conveyancing machination insulted my
crystal ball and he still won't have a
number all right and last but not least
what's your number Harry oh I think
those people are not answering your
question I think if I don't if I'm not
asking to view this kind of system I
would say you know if I understand your
question it's really we really talking
about fifty to a hundred years that we
may be able to build these kind of
capabilities okay and then we have one
more number of records right who spoke
this morning it's been talking a lot
about 20 29 just 14 years from now let's
give or take a little bit so this is
very interesting because of course their
worst nightmare when you're in the
audience is sit and listen to a panel
wherever
but he just agrees with everybody else
like yeah yeah and you get this mutual
admiration society going and you take
out your laptop or that's not the case
we're very fortunate we had infinity we
had 50 to 100 years we had won't answer
but probably in Gordon's lifetime here
at 300 years so why don't we each go
around and I think you should go this
one you want to start here why do you
think it's too big why are you more
optimistic than Barbara I think we're
gonna get you never c never know that's
I think that you just have to really
look at that you know from somewhat a
scientific point of view you look at the
data you have then you mix sudden
predictions and the hopefully you have a
couple of chance to eat irate in a very
fine to see what's going on I think I
have been very encouraged by the
progress in this AI fields you know 25
years ago when I started walking in AI
in robotics in graduate school it was
kind of know the beginning of the middle
of that AI winter no people was the
hardest fish thing would never work he
looked at his everywhere never really
dropped that fast but I see that's a lot
of opportunities there and as a steward
earlier earlier you mentioned that they
are good reasons why you know now is
actually also a good time to push things
moving forward I do believe that you
know this progress would be more spiral
we don't really know when it'll be a big
jump I think there will be tough tough
scientific research problems such as
modeling and certainty general knowledge
representation those problems we have to
address I'm afraid that I wouldn't be
able to see that in my my lifetime so I
feel very comfortable predicting any
number when I'm gone and do you want to
push back on this you said infinite
eating so there's quickly something you
think that he's over optimistic about
that or not to be bi I I advisedly asked
this question about the hypothalamus and
about emotion and about psychotherapy I
because I think I mean it's also an
ethical question right I think there are
things that human beings Oh each other
and we talked about this in the preview
the previous panel on human-computer
interaction
there are things that we shouldn't
delegate to machines so if you want to
leave those things out of the mix then
then one could answer a question about
the kinds of intelligence that we think
we might want to delegate to machines
and will when will they surpass us then
I would say they already have in search
they're much better at searching than I
am they've been better than us at
arithmetic for a long time and and I
think we will I think we will continue
to see AI and intelligent systems doing
more and more things in the domains in
which machines can be more intelligent
than us in in perpetuity now um just I
clarified just a clear item I don't want
an Ava from right x mark on it I don't
think this is a reasonable practical go
Google does ray me go google deepmind
says their goal is to build a superhuman
general-purpose intelligence and there's
550 highly trained people sitting there
in an office building in London do
exactly that so this is a question right
if some extent it doesn't matter what we
want because people see I mean I think
Google from the beginning has seen its
goal as to have superhuman AI
capabilities as a massive economic asset
that this would enable I'm essentially
to control a large part of the world
economy but do they do they really mean
to replace psychotherapist I think they
don't see that as a big part of the
world to answer Maxis question he's not
really disagreeing with me he's changing
the topic so just to make sure we're all
on the same page and then to clarify
here michael has the great success
managed to simulate quite complicated
molecular systems suppose in the future
thanks to the Moore's law Michael
simulates the entire HIPAA thalamus or
suppose some other person and 500 years
simulates your entire brain and do you
think that that system would then by
definition be as capable as
the human except in silicon or do you
think that in other words are you did
you guess infinity because you think
that it's fundamentally impossible to
help you man I or do you think did you
say infinity because you think people
will choose not to build these things
because we shouldn't which of those two
there you know obviously to my students
I love or questions cuz then i can say
yes but I I said infinity for the second
reason did you think we shouldn't go
there and you think we mean I'm not like
I think I think there are many great
directions to go with intelligent
systems i should say i don't actually
like the label artificial intelligence
with all due respect I prefer machine
intelligence and intelligent systems and
I think they will become more and more
powerful and they will complement us in
many many ways and that that's really
how I even if you want my protection for
the future that's my prediction for the
future varied rather than replacing us
yeah and Michael you said 300 years is
this because you think again that people
will not want to go there or do you
think it's good to be very Mars this was
the opening bid so yeah baby in the
promotion I i I'd really like Barbara's
idea about just things you don't do and
in the same way that we don't clone
people we really preps it and you know
and and again when you talk about a
computer that is indistinguishable from
a human this is like a super Turing test
so I would live with somebody for a year
and I would know whether they were
personally human you know what exactly
what is it going to be so I think that I
don't think it's actually that
interesting intake is exactly that I
think key thing is how we're going to
use what worries me much much more let's
just imagine that in 10 years time you
can make troops that are robots that are
basically invincible you know it maybe
this is an answer of the enlightened
world against them not enlightened world
it's a terrible answer you know I just
don't know but only in the same way we
don't use chemical weapons we hardly use
nuclear weapons and so you know I think
that they need to be limits set
I was a find it quite difficult to
distinguish between artificial
intelligence and computing so for
example is my iphone an artificial
intelligence device is it an interface
device is it a calculating machine my
feeling is that it certainly egg ments
my intelligence and as such I am very
happy to see it as artificial
intelligence so I you know I think that
there's no doubt that computing is going
to become more and more important
everything we do and I hope we can
really get things better I think the
fact that world poverty has fallen by a
factor of two in 25 years which is
unbelievable yeah I don't even believe
the numbers I bet there has a lot of
technical technological input to that
those are really nice perspectives and
we have a lot certainly to be optimistic
about their where is shortly going to go
to some audience questions during our
last five minutes just to spur you in
the audience to ask questions let me ask
one last quickie round that all of you
here again so we saw a poll this morning
we're about two-thirds of you here in
the room guessed that we would get human
level artificial intelligence in this
century so let's for a moment give our
audience the benefit of the doubt
regardless of what what what we said
here on stage suppose some time in the
century or even later we do get the
human level intelligence then my
question is and here again you should
just say a number for your answer on a
scale from 0 to 10 how do you feel about
this where where where how concerned do
you feel where 10 means you're really
quite concerned that it might go bad 0
means you're absolutely do not worry at
all and you feel so guaranteed
everything is going to be fine so
supportive right we'll get human level
at some point how worried are you zero
all right an optimist ah if by human
level intelligence you mean at least the
ethical standards that most human beings
have and I'm not worried if you mean
that we're just creating intelligent in
some other abstract sense with a with no
as Stuart would actually refer to a
value system but I'll say
no ethics built into the way it operates
and I would be very concerned okay
Stewart uh seven so I think I get to
know what Barbara said but she were
being good in case I'm a number yes yeah
so I coming back to the question of
robots invincible robot soldiers this is
i would say balanced on a knife-edge we
could see within five or ten years that
most of the major powers are actually
operating their defense systems largely
using autonomous weapons which I think
could be extremely unstable and quite
dangerous situation with those weapons
be able to take take your rock I mean
we're not not just fighter bombers I go
in there and occupied territory uh yes
yes I mean you could you could imagine
yeah thousand such robots who would go
in and yeah that's it required okay why
don't just make sure the harry gets a
before we go to court in so just to
clarify heavens we're gonna meetings
actually he's really worried about but
it clearly has the hope that we can get
things right yeah he didn't say 10 yes
no then I'm exactly you know 10-7 so I
actually goes three I would say of
course we should be worried about and I
actually was talking to you Barbara in
at lunch time that the ethics ethics
concerns we should have as we develop
this kind of technology especially in on
the emotional side with human being and
of course you know is this kind of
powerful technology you know potential
you know powerful weapons and other
things we mentioned about with robots
and the way they are we have to be very
careful you know how we actually use
this kind of technology just like how we
actually use nuclear weapons know those
things right just that you cannot go all
the way down to zero at all so you have
to be concerned good I want to just get
the order to give the audience a chance
to ask a couple of quick questions
before we don't want to be the one
standing between them and coffee that's
not good so we have microphones out here
make sure your questions are brief and
that they actually are questions it's
not statements and we'll try to answer
briefly to max can I say something yeah
while we get the question right go for
it I want to pick up on something that
um that Michael said which is he thinks
of AI
computing is the same thing and as we
think about the risk the risk of cyber
warfare of cybersecurity permeates all
of this there's also the risk of the
handoffs that I that I talked about and
there's the risks of buddy but buggy
code which also permeates all of this so
I think that the fact that AI and
computing are so closely intertwined
means that the risks are closely
intertwined as well a very good point so
quick questions and we'll try to do
quick answers it's squeezing a couple
who is the keeper of the mic we start by
saying your name and also who you are
yeah my name is axel and i'm studying
cognitive science here in Gothenburg and
I hope we can frame this right but do
you believe that the artificial
intelligence or intelligence machines
can must have a human form or a human
element to be for us to be able to
interact well with them it's a bit of an
interaction question maybe but yeah who
feels most eager to feel this one is the
one person for each question since we're
out of time who wants to take this so
the answer is no that that computers can
interact quite well with people without
pretending to be people and the on the
previous panel we actually talked about
how important it was or several of us
talked about how important it was to be
able to interpret what people's emotions
in their state but to also be clear
about not being a human when you
communicate back Fox I would like to
propose a ban on robots that are two
humanoid I think they should be
morphologically distinct
from humans maybe have four legs into
them so that they're not fooling us
because I think it's really a formless
dishonesty yeah something in a human
form that that just isn't here in any
way that's why 11 last audience question
yes my name is very kind I'm the
president of Swedish AI society i'm
curious to know what areas of AI do you
think is underdeveloped we have a lot of
students in the audience so what areas
of AI is underdeveloped that you would
see more work on all of them hahaha I
think of it I give you a very quick
answer I I really think that you know
today we have this huge in a
concentration of a sudden specific areas
like a vision like a speech I really
hope that we have more brilliant
students to study the general knowledge
representation I think this is really
very very important if I may add one
more thing I would also say there are
just so many very importantly I
applications that we should also study
my current favorite is actually I for
medical applications that if you think
about that the United States alone you
know every year four hundred thousand
people die off and a preventable errors
medical errors with the data with the
computer with the AI technology we can
save a lot of lives great lots of
optimism there so to summarize we've
heard from our panelists here that
there's quite uniform optimism in the
near term a lot of great possibilities
and this time we're not going to get an
AI winter because it's happening and
looking a little bit farther afield is
so again great prospects for wonderful
things coming out of this as long as we
don't do stupid things and I think the
clear message was here that we which you
both which all of you really nicely
phrase is we when you give you said it's
going to be a seven if this other y0 is
that we shouldn't think of the future as
something that's going to happen to us
as if weirdest pathetic passive
bystanders who have no impact we are the
masters of our own destiny we are
shaping our own future and I think the
optimistic and no to take away from what
we've heard here is that we should
clearly figure out what sort of future
we want and build that one
not the bad one so let's thank our
wonderful panel we're really stimulating
discussion and we continue again in 26
minutes after you've gotten caffeinated
out there thank you that should be on
the back